we don't deserve you or this outfit or
your music I don't deserve you look at
you I wish wins tonight I think we're
pulling out some looks tonight is
Grammys week okay leave it on the Jews
I'm obsessed with cities
[Music]
you're having a phenomenal week I mean
between Ellen how does it feel to be
getting all this love I mean it feels
really good I've been working my ass off
for a long time everybody knows the
people who know no and right now I just
feel like it's what we deserve you know
we've been killing it and now we get to
kill it on the main stage so I'm just
enjoying this weekend cuz next year it's
gonna be crazy cuz I'll be nominated ok
you gonna speak into a man Jesus who you
trying to meet this weekend oh my
goodness beyond saying you think she
gonna be there I don't think she's gonna
be there listen I don't you know me I'm
just always dying to meet Beyonce where
she at you got Coachella coming up how's
that coming the preparing listen we had
to get through Ellen and Fallon yeah
we're focusing on Coachella now and tour
Georgia sold out in the pre-sale so now
we got a we got to make up for that we
got to give them a good ass show and
your new album comes out in April to a
pronounced out April 19 what's one word
you would use to describe it oh my god
[ __ ] the DNA test came in and you're
100% that damn [ __ ] know I can do a
family friendly word it's gonna be
soulful so powerful congratulations
[Music]